-Our first guest, tonight,
if she's still here...
[ Laughter ]
...is a United States senator
from Massachusetts.
Her children's book,
"Pinkie Promises,"
is available now.
Please welcome back to the show
Senator Elizabeth Warren,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome, welcome!
-Thank you!
-I'm so happy to have you here.
-I'm so happy to be here.
I'm so happy to be here!
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm just so glad
to be with people
who are not the people I'm with
in Washington all the time.
-Yeah.
-You -- You know,
you did us a favor.
You were our second guest when
we went into lockdown, via Zoom.
-Yeah.
-And the issue that time was --
-I had a table lamp next to me,
you know, staring into
the lights, and, yeah.
-Right.
It was the early days,
where none of us
knew how to Zoom.
You had a dog that you had --
You had to lock your dog
in a bedroom.
-That's right, that's right.
-Yeah.
We have scratches on the back
of the door that say,
"I could do better
on 'Seth Meyers.'"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I know.
-So, it's nice
that we're past that.
And now, obviously,
you mentioned Washington.
I do want to get right into it.
Right now,
President Biden is trying
to institute the things
he ran on.
-Yeah.
-Expanding Medicare,
child care, clean energy.
These are things that poll well
with the American people.
And yet, it seems like, for
those of us that pay attention,
that it's moving very slowly.
-Mm-hmm.
-Do you feel like the Democrats
are doing a good enough job
telling people
what's in this bill?
Because it seems like we all
know the number, $3.5 trillion.
It seems like the Republicans,
and the opponents of this bill,
have done a good job, and maybe
the media has helped them
make that what we think about.
-Right.
-But can you talk about
what's in this bill
and why it's important?
-So, this is not about numbers.
Think --
Think of it this way.
Starting more
than a century ago,
America started investing
in our country, in ourselves.
So we built roads and bridges,
we built power grids,
and sewers and water lines,
we opened up public schools,
and public colleges
and universities.
We made those investments,
because it was a way to make us
collectively a richer country,
and a way to create opportunity,
person by person,
throughout this nation.
And then,
we kind of went into coasting
about 40 years ago or so.
And we just kind of slowed
way down on those investments.
And the world changed around us.
So, now we find ourselves --
here we are in 2021.
We need to make
some big changes.
And here's the exciting part.
We've got our toes
right on the line
to make big structural change
in this nation.
Child care,
so that every parent
will have a chance
to be able to go to work.
Raise the wages
of every child-care worker
and preschool teacher
in America.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Home- and community-based care.
Expanding -- Expanding Medicare
so people get vision, dental,
and hearing coverage.
[ Applause ]
And the really, really big one
is not just taking a nibble,
not just a pat, but we've got
to take a big, hard swing
at fighting back
in the climate crisis.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All of that at stake.
-So, again, good news.
That seems great to me,
seems great to everybody here,
probably most
of the people watching.
I'm afraid
Senators Manchin and Sinema
probably aren't watching
tonight.
[ Audience groans ]
It strikes me that you have
these two people -- right? --
who are --
they have
all the power right now.
And --
-No.
No, they don't have it all.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
No!
-Well, they could stop it.
If they wanted to,
they could stop it.
I mean the power that way.
And it does seem like --
You know, again,
I'm watching from a distance,
but it does seem like
they are pretty firm
in their position that they
don't want to get this passed.
So what is the way to make them
change their mind?
Is it to apply political
pressure and try to sell
the American people
on why this is a good idea?
-That's a big part of it.
Look, this is a democracy.
And part of this is, remember,
everything that
we're talking about here
is really, really popular.
The American people get it.
Washington lives
in its own bubble --
a bubble, I should say,
that is deeply infected
by lobbyists and the folks
who are always trying to --
you know, they're there
for the billionaires,
they're there
for the giant corporations.
But the rest of America --
Democrat, Republican,
Independent -- they get it.
These are the investments
we need to make
if we are going to be
a strong nation going forward.
If we're going to be a country,
that, instead of
narrowing opportunity,
actually expands opportunity.
So to the extent
that we do something besides
talk about a number, which
I say this as a numbers nerd,
makes a lot of people fall
asleep or just get aggravated
or watch it
like it's some kind of race.
If we actually talk about
the things that this is about,
the kinds of changes
it will make in people's lives,
the kind of opportunity that
we're about to create together,
I think
that is how we get it done.
And by the way,
we need to do that now.
-So here's the thing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not only do you have to
do it now,
but it also strikes me --
let's say you get it done.
-Say that again.
-Let's say you can get it done.
-Okay. I'm liking that.
-But, then, how quickly --
-Let's do it.
-Because I think that one of
the things that's frustrating --
people are frustrated
by both parties --
is the speed in which you
actually can show results.
-Yep.
-So, if you get it done,
it seems very important
that you would be able
to show to the American people,
certainly before
the midterm elections,
"Hey, look,
we made your lives better.
We controlled government,
the Democratic Party,
and we had
this two-year period of time
where you gave us the reins."
And, you know, people
are gonna go to the polls,
you're gonna have to be able
to show them
that you made
their lives better.
Can you do this quickly?
Can child care be something
that people see before
they go back to the polls?
-We have to.
And child care, actually,
is the perfect example.
We cannot take a sort of
leisurely, "Yes, we're gonna
have child care done,"
and tell the mamas of
2-year-olds and 3-year-olds
that we'll have this done
by the time your kid is 6 or 7.
You know, we --
we can't do that.
We have to say, "We are going to
bust our fannies
to get this stuff
and get it delivered
and create the child-care slots,
raise the wages
of the child-care workers."
Remember, though, before you
giggle about whether or not
we can do this,
we did it with vaccinations.
We did it
with the child tax credit.
We did it with those
$1,200 checks
that we put in people's pockets
for relief.
We didn't do it
with rental relief.
We handed it out the states,
and said, "Hey, take your time.
Work this out."
It did not work.
So we better learn a lesson from
that, and we better deliver,
deliver big, and deliver now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, I think it would help
a lot of families,
and I really do hope
you're successful with that.
We'll be right back with more
from Senator Elizabeth Warren.